I'm an entrepreneur I'm a capitalist you
know it's when I look at my neighborhood
right now you don't see UPS trucks
anymore you see Amazon why because
Amazon has the edge in business they are
on top of it they delivered their
employees are not complaining they are
not on strike everybody has business
everybody is happy they are delivering
the product UPS just dropped it and they
dropped it big time and you know this is
a good lesson like you said fired the
ones who are complaining shrink your
budget and then you know let them
understand how lucky they are to have a
job the way UPS drivers
$170,000 pay package okay has some
Amazon drivers thinking it's time to
quit they make 18 bucks an hour that's
36 Grand a year wow can you by the way
can you imagine UPS Union 170